ministers of Agriculture and Fisheries
meeting on Monday in Brussels discussed
the future of the EU milk sector
following the end of the quota system in
2015 some countries express their
concerns about potential price
volatility and asked for additional
measures to address it in particular in
the case of vulnerable milk production
areas ministers also welcomed the plans
presented by the Commission to bring
together and simplify to currently
separate school schemes the school fruit
scheme and the school milk scheme
delegations agreed that the proposed
scheme will contribute to improving
healthy eating habits among
schoolchildren it will also help to
foster link between schoolchildren and
agriculture although Member States see
the advantages of the unified scheme in
terms of public health some have doubts
that it offers a real simplification the
council also discussed the new
promotional rules for European
agricultural products which aim to open
up new markets for these products and to
increase consumer awareness of their
quality but there are different views as
to whether the new information and
promotion measures should concentrate on
the internal market or rather on the
foreign markets to avoid a distortion of
competition in the EU finally ministers
listen to the priorities of the Greek EU
presidency which include wrapping up the
work on the reformed Common Agricultural
Policy finalizing the agreement with the
European Parliament on the European
maritime and Fisheries fund and moving
ahead with the food chain legislation
package